قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
اكثر من الاوروبيين بشان حادثه الصاروخ في
بولندا مشددا على انه ما كان ينبغي التسرع
من قبل بعض الدول باطلاق تصريحات زادت
الموقف تصعيدا بينما لا صله لروسيا بذلك
الحدث وكان قادتنا امريكيون قد اكدوا ان
مصدر الصاروخ دفاعات اوكرانيه وان التحقيق
بشان ذلك مستمر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا لنا في نقاشه
مسارات ثلاثه ما تفسير حرصي اطراف الصناعي
على سرعه احتواء الازمه وابقائها في حدود
اوكرانيا
هل يتضمن اقرار الكريم للباحترافيه
الولايات المتحده في التعامل مع الحادثه
رسائل غزل روسيه الى واشنطن قد تمهدوا
لمرحله جديده
ما هي افاق الصراع وما الضمانات من عدم
اتساع نطاق الحرب بالنظر بمثل هذه المواقف
[موسيقى]
لم تكن روسيا من اطلق الصاروخ اذا وتم
تطويق الحادث ضمن ارتدادات محدوده لم
تتجاوز مصارعه اعضاء الناتو لابداء
لانشغال والتعاطف والاستعداد لمؤازره دوله
عضو حقيقه لا تمنع بحسب واشنطينه تستمر
التحقيقات لاستكمال صوره ما حدث على واقع
اشاره الايجابيه من موسكو التي اشارت
باحترافيه واشنطن في التعامل مع الموضوع
مقابل ما وصافه المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ايجار
بتصريحات تشكل استفزازا متعمدا صدرت عن
القياده الاخرانيه وغيرها
مروه
عاليه الدقه تم تنفيذها ضد اهداف على
اراضي اوكرانيه فقط وعلى مسافه لا تقل عن
35 كلم من الحدود الاوكرانيه البولنديه من
خلال صور الحطام التي عثر عليها في قريه
شيودوف وبشكل لابسه فيه حدد خبراء روس
انها اجزاء لصاروخ مضاد للطائرات من طراز
300 تابعا للدفاع الجوي الاوكراني نعتبر
تصريحات مصادر اوكرانيه ومسؤولين اجانب
بشان سقوط صواريخ روسيه مدعومه في قريه
استفزازا متعمدا هدفه تصعيد الموقف
الامين العام لحلفي الاطلسيه يانسمبرج قال
في ختامه الاجتماع انه لا تاكيدات لدى
الحلف على ان اطلاق الصاروخي على بولندا
كان متعمدا ولا على ان روسيا تقوم باعمال
ضد النيتو
لا مؤشرات على هجوم متعمد على بولندا
وليست لدينا مؤشرات على ان روسيا تحضر
عمليه عسكريه هجوميه ضد النيته على الارجح
الصاروخ الذي سقط في بولندا اطلقته
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه خلال اعتراض
صواريخ الروسيه
وبين الشبهات والاتهامات جاء الموقف
الامريكي من اعلى مستوى ليؤكد انه لا يد
لروسيا في الصاروخ الذي سقط على الاراضي
البولنديه دون ايلغى ذلك ضروره التحقيق
والاجتماع بين سفراء الممثلين للدول
الاعضاء في حلف الاطلسي والمتابع ما قاله
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في قمه العشرين
الى ان الصواريخ
يجب ان ننتظر انتهاء التدقيق في الامر كله
من غير المحتمل انها اطلقت من روسيا
بالنظر الى ما رصد من مسارها وقد نعقد
اجتماعا للسفراء الممثلين لدول حلف شمال
الاطلسي
وبين هذا وذاك عاد الرئيس الاوكراني
يؤكد من جديد في اخر تصريحاته ان الصاروخ
الذي سقط في الاراضي البولنديه هو صاروخ
روسي
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور دونالدز الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
السابق في موسكو امانه من موسكو
الصحافه الدوريه بجاموس العلاقات الدوليه
ورده بيضاء هنا بال واشنطن الدكتور جونسون
كان هنالك مصارعه
اوروبيه في الواقع وايضا امريكيه لكنها
جاءت اولا من الرئيس الامريكي جو بيدن الى
نفي صله روسيا بهذا الصاروخ
واحتواء هذه الازمه في مهدها ما تفسيرك
لهذا التسارع الغربي الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده لاحتواء هذه الازمه مبكرا بهذه
الطريقه
متى خطوره الحرب العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا كان حادثه غلط في الحسابات او او
بعد معرفه مواقف الاخرين قد يؤدي ذلك الى
اسمع عالميه وربما هذه مره ثانيه
وثانيا همم وذكر مشاهديكم بان اوكرانيه من
اجل حياتها ضد حرب روسيه قاسيه عدوانيه
وغزوا عليها وبالتالي منها الطبيعي يعني
عندما يسقط صاروخ الماء على اراضي في
هولندا فان الشعب يتوقعون سوء تصرف من
روسيا مره اخرى وثانيه نوضح بين الولايات
المتحده وحلفاء الغربيين اتخذوا قاموا
بتخيما حريص ودقيق جدا حول ما حصل فعلا
وما جرى وحدد موقفهم ذلك
خاصه
ليست ان ليله امس كانوا حذرين جدا في
تقييم الموقف
لانه كان الامر يتطلب كشف الحقائق ثم
اتخاذ قرار حول ما حصل ثم احتساب النتائج
الكسندر جورنو من موسكو ما هو تفسيرك انت
ايضا لهذا الحرص المتبادل في الواقع من
روسيا وايضا من الغرب من الليتو من الرئيس
الامريكي على احتواء الازمه مبكرا
اه طيب اعود مره اخرى لانه ضيفنا بالموسكو
غير جاهز اعود مره اخرى الى الدوله
هنالك تصريحات مع ذلك للرئيس الاوكراني
بان الصاروخ روسي ماذا لو كان الصاروخ
روسيه
من حسب ما قراته اليوم صباحا كان اي 3
يستخدمه الاوكرانيون لا اعرف لماذا
قام بهذا العمل لكن مره اخرى اقول الحوادث
في الحروب تحصل مره اخرى
غلط في الحساب اذا المهم هو هو ان
اوكرانيا تدافع عن نفسها بافضل ما تستطيع
ضد العدوان الروسي هذا هو الموضوع الرئيسي
ولا ينبغي شده انتباه هنا بامور قد تكون
رغم انه ماساويه فان مثل هذه الامور يمكن
يشتت الانتباه عن الرساله الرئيسيه
الاساسيه وهي ان روسيا تغزوا اوكرانيا
لتدافع عن نفسها بشكل مثير للاعجاب وفي
مثل هذا الوضع احيانا تحصل اخطاء سيئه
احيانا تحصل اخطاء واشياء سيئه لكن هذه
هذا الشيء الذي حدث تم احتوائه مبكرا جدا
اعود الى ضيفنا من موسكو اليكساندر غو نوف
تفسيره لمسارعه موسكو ومصارعه واشنطن
وباريس وايضا برلين الى احتواء هذه الازمه
في مهدها
في موسكو كانت هي الدهشه كان هناك
هشتريه من طرف دلينسكي الذي بدا يدعوا
النيته لان يبدا
بالانضمام
معارك وكان روسيا تهاجم بولندا
وكان يتحدث في الجيش 20
كان يذكر ان بالمعارك التي كانت في
التاريخ
محوريه
وكان يقول عليكم ان تبداوا الان من هذه
اللحظه عليكم ان تعلموا ان دول النيته
ودول الغرب
لم يتحولوا للقانون الخامس من قوانين
الناتو بل
دعوا لمجلس استشاري وقالوا ان الدول ليس
مستعدين لتواجه مباشر مع روسيا ولكنهم سوف
يستمروا
بايقاف روسيا بايدي اوكران انهم مرتاحين
للاوضاع التي هي الان انهم يحاربون
اوكرانا اوكرانيا بالاموال الاوروبيه
والايدي يحارب روسيا بالايدي الاوكرانيه
الاوروبيه وكان السفير البولندي في روسيا
اليوم قد دعي لسفاره الخارج ودارت
الخارجيه الروسيه
قلنا له ان ردت فعل بولندا كانت تنشر
المزاج الكاره لروسيا وقلنا ان
بولندا تحاول ان تزيد واوضاع صعوبه
ومع ذلك هولندا هولندا على لسان رئيسها
وعلى ايضا لسان وزاره الدفاع نفذ ايضا ان
يكون هذا الصاروخ روسيا بل نفت ان تكون قد
دعت الى تفعيل الماده الرابعه وسنتحدث هذا
الماده الرابعه من حلف النيته بعد قليل
لكن ايضا من اللافت ما قاله مستشار
الالماني همم
الذي حذر مما وصفه باي استنتاجات المتسرعه
قبل اجراء تحقيق الدقيق بشان سقوط الصاروخ
في بولندا واضاف المستشار الالماني في
مؤتمر الصحفي خلال حضوره قمه العشرين
المنعقده في اندونيسيا قال كل هذا ما كان
ليحدث لولا الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اريد ان اسالك مره اخرى على الاجزاء اندر
جورنو عن هذه المواقف مهو هناك مواقف
فرنسيه مواقف المانيه ايضا الموقف
البولندي الذي نفى صله روسيا انا اعرف
اريد ان اعرف قراءتك انت لمسارعه النيتو
ومصارعه الدول الاوروبيه ومصارعه الولايات
المتحده لنفي صله روسيا بهذا الصاروخ
رده الفعل كانت
تقول ان
ليست مستعده لمواجهه روسيا مباشره
لا يقوم بالتحقيق بالصواريخ التي وقعت على
التراكتور البولندي
ويحقق في تدمير خطوط الانابيب
نورتريم هذه الانابيب التي تعتبر همم ملك
للمانيا النار
انا السيد جوبيدر ااه ضغط على الجميع فورا
ما اكد ان هناك دلائل امريكيه ان الصاروخ
كان اوكرانيا فورا هدا الجميع في اوروبا
وبولندا بدات تطالب بالدفاع عنها من قبل
المانيا
وتذكره ان هناك المليارات التي صرفت على
هذه الحرب الى مواقعهم العاديه
يعني يؤيده الواقع ان البدايه كانت ان
الصاروخ روسي تصريحات بولنديه ثم قبل بعد
قبل قبل ذلك تصريحات اوكرانيه ثم تحدث
الرئيس الامريكي
ويعني تقريبا عازفها الاوروبيون على على
نفس السيمفونيه على نفس اللحن ان الصاروخ
همم اوكراني وليس وليس روسي ما هي قراءتك
لاتخاذ الاداره الامريكيه هذه المسافه
من تصريحات الرئيس الاوكراني والمسؤولين
الاوكرانيين
عندما ننشر الخطوط الرعايه السياسيه
الروسيه الاولى ان الحلفاء
والروسنين
وقد درسوا الادله والتعليقه
ولا هذا هذا ليس الوضع كما هو الضيف
الروسي
اعتقد ان هذا يثبت ايضا ان هناك
اهتمام يبين تصميم اوروبا المتحده على
تجنب مواجهه روسيا بشكل كبير وهذا وليس ما
تقوله روسيا وهم يقولون ما ما هيحصل هل هو
انا نيته كان تحاول ان تحكم على الحقائق
كما تراها ليتخذوا قرارا وقال اللي قرار
هو ان هذا كان حادثا عرضيا ولكن اساس هنا
هو انهم من المنطقي انه يفكر بان روسيا
يمكن ان تقوم مثل هذا العمل بسبب السلوك
الروسي في ماكن اخرى الغزو لاوكرانيا وقصف
المدن والمدنيين واذكر كل من يشاهدنا لان
هذا حصل امس في خدمه هجوم روسي كبير جدا
على البنى التحتيه المدنيه
الطاقه الكهربائيه والتدفئه الروس
الكبرى وهي السلوك روسيا همم في كل مكان
في اوكرانيا وليس على شيء هو ماساوي لكن
متحده
بعض الناس في وسطه من الصباح اليوم
من اللفت ايضا ان روسيا
دقيقه يعني كانت حريصه على استخدام لغه
مختلفه هذه المره هذه المره فرقت بين رد
الفعل الاوروبي وبين رد الفعل الامريكي
قالت ان رد الفعل الامريكي كان اكثر
احترافيه من رد الفعل الاوروبي ما الرساله
من وراء ذلك
المفاوضات التي كانت في اسطنبول منذ يومين
بين
المخابرات الروسيه وكما اعلم من مصادر ان
في هذه المفاوضات
وصلوا الى تفاهم انه في
غد النظر
الاوضاع وكيف سوف تتطور في اوكرانيا او
غير ذلك من الممنوع ان يسمح ان همم يكون
هناك بين امريكا وروسيا كدولتين نوويتين
ان يكون هناك تصعيد الى مستوى الصراع
النووي هذا شيء من الممنوع المستحيل ان
يصل له
الكثير يسالون لشخصيه
يا جميله
بنقد ما قاله السيد بيدن همم لان هناك سبب
واضح لان العسكريين
ان روسيا بطريقه عسكريه دون استخدام اسلحه
نوويه من المستحيل الانتصار على روسيا
واستخدام السلاح النووي ضد يدمر امريكا
في حلقه اخرى لكن هذه الرساله
الروسيه فيما يتعلق بالتفريق بين رد الفعل
الاوروبي ورد الفعل
الامريكي كيف ينبغي ان تقراها واشنطن
دكتور دونالدز جونسون من واشنطن هل هل
هنالك رساله هل هل نبالغ اذا قلنا ان
هنالك رساله روسيه للولايات المتحده ربما
تمهد
لتفاوض ما ل- لتسويه ما
والله الاكشن
واعتقد ان السيد وزير اردنيه
كان له علاقه بالاسلحه النوويه وغيرها من
المسائل مثل
الاعتقال الغير معه كل احد الاشخاص في
موسكو ودن الاداره ترى رايها واضح لن تكون
هناك مفاوضات حاليا
جدا الان ولكن رغم ذلك انا شخصيا اعتقد
انهم مفيد جدا
اهتمام المشترك سواء كان خطاب التهور
في سبتمبر بوتن ايضا قراره لاحقا او حول
قضايا اخرى
اذا هذا ليس تناقض ان يدعم اوكرانيا وندعم
كتب من اج عمتها ووجودها وفي الوقت ذاته
ان يكون لدينا تواصل مفتوح مع روسيا هناك
امثله كثيره في السنوات الماضيه حول جوانب
التي تكون في حاله
حربها دلاله الحديث حتى وهو اثناء
قتاليهالهم وهذا امر
افتتاحه بالفعل للتواصل لمنع ذلك همم بين
النت وبين روسيا في بدايات هذه الحرب لكن
الرئيس الهولندي على سبيل المثال وهذا ما
يقوده الى الماده الرابعه في الليل
والرئيس البولندي اند جيده قال ان بلاده
الله ترى ضروره لتفعيل الماده الرابعه من
ميثاق النيته بشان سقوط الصاروخ هذه
الماده الرابعه من معاهده النيته على ان
اي دوله عضو في نيته تشعر بالتهديد من قبل
دوله اخرى او منظمه الارهابيه لا الحق في
تقديم طلب لبدء الدول الاعضاء مشاورات
الرسميه للبت فيها اذا كان التهديد موجود
البث فيما اذا كانت موجوده في تحديد كيفيه
مواجهه هذا مع التواصلي الى قرارات
بالاجماع وهنا اريد ان اعود الى ضيفي من
همم موسكو مره اخرى اليكزاندر اجورنو فيما
يتعلق بهذه الماده طبعا هولندا لم تفاعل
هذه الماده لكن هذه الماده فاعلت من قبل
حوالي سبع مرات همم وفي مرات ايضا تم
تفعيل الماده الخامسه همم الى اي مدى هذا
يمثل خطوره لتطور الصراع في المستقبل
وخروجه عن حدوده اوكرانيا
علمونا ان بالنسبه لروسيا
استطيع ان اؤكد لكم انه على اساس
اللقاءات التي كانت على مختلف المستويات
في روسيا استطيع ان اقول ان روسيا لا تخطط
ولا تفكر حتى
بان يتوسع هذا النزاع خلف حدود اوكرانيا
بالعكس ان
الاغلبيه يريدون ان ينهوا ان النزاع باسرع
وقت ممكن حتى يكون على الضحايا من الطرفين
اقل ما يمكن وهذا موقف السيد بوتين وهذا
ما ادعمه شخصيا ان اجداد عاشوا في
اوكرانيا ليس هناك نحن شعب واحد طيب
لذلك
ايضا
يعني خطاب الضمانات قبل الحرب فشله في منع
هذه الحرب هل هل يمكن لاي ضمارات الان انت
تنهي هذه الحرب
باختصار لو سمحت
برنامج
اوكرانيا بلد مختلف ومجتمع مختلف وهذا جزء
مشكله في روسيا لا تفهم ذلك اما في الوقت
الحالي فحوله سؤال لك الوقت في الوقت
حاليا مفاوضات فعلا
موجوده بشكل غير مباشر والموقف العسكري
الروسي ضعيف نسبيا
واوكرانيون يحققون تقدم في ساحات المعارض
وليس هناك همم
اعتقد ان الامر هذا قد يستمر مع الاسير في
فتره الطويله على البضاعه اخرى وعلي ان
ننتظر ما الذي سيحصل بعد الشتاء حاليا
اعتقد ان اي فرصه اي مفاوضات اطلاقا لان
نعرف ان موسكو تريد ان تكون مفاوضات
شروطها هي وهذا غير مقبول من الغرب وايضا
قبل كل شيء مرفوض من الاوكرانيا وعلينا
ننتظر
لنعمل التحقيق السلام لكن ليس وقت التفاوض
جزيلا
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا دكتور جانسون
الدبلوماسيه الامريكي السابق في موسكو من
موسكو
مشكورنوف استاذ الصحافه الدوليه بجامعه
موسكو العلاقات الدوليه
[موسيقى]